- I'm been there, to where
I wanted to walk away,
but I was afraid because I
saw other people try to do it,
and I saw what happened,
and I remember how, one
day, me and the homie,
we went up to the school,
me, you, and him,
and we went up to the
school to smoke some weed,
and he was, like, dog, lets
get somethin' to drink.
He was, like, askin' me,
"Whatchu got?"
I, like, shit.
And if somebody's askin' you,
lets chip in on the drink,
and you got money, and you
refusing to give up some,
you know, we might have some problems.
So, I was, like, I got
somethin' on the drink.
He asked homie Anthony,
He was like,
"Man, I ain't gonna be
puttin' no money on no drink.
And, while we's sittin'
there, getting high,
the homie confronted him,
and slapped him so
hard, dog, it scared me!
And he was the one runnin'!
When he slapped him, shit!
That mofo seemed like he
slapped the shit outta me,
and I didn't even get slapped!
Then, he was, like,
"SB, lets get 'im!"
He ran, up like shit!
I don't wanna get 'im.
Shit, I wanna go to the house!
No good, this is somethin' to think about.
You know, if I'm gonna give up no money,
and you gonna slap me, you
know, this makes you think.
Homie slapped the shit outta
this nigga, Anthony, man!
And I was like, damn!
I got a homie named Big Will.
He dead now,
because eventually, when
you doin' whatchu do,
it's gonna catch up to you.
And man, one of the little homies
was arguing with this other little dude,
Big Will come outside, he
figurin' to knock the nigga out,
and get some points from you,
knowin' that you the dope dealer,
that you goin' look out for him, anyway.
So Big Will knock him out.
When he wake up, he ask who knock him out?
The Lum, we tell him,
"Big Will knock you out."
Where the gun come in at, I don't know.
But, the way I heard it was,
they gave him a gun, to get the homie.
But I think he went to his
own hood, and got a gun,
came back, and they was
drivin' down the street,
Big Will ridin' down
the street on a bicycle,
and they see 'im.
And shoot 'im.
Killed 'im.
This one dude, that grew up
with me, man, he was, like,
one of the best friends
I could of ever wanted.
One of the best role
models, as a brother, to me.
'Cause he wouldn't let
nobody fuck with me wrong.
If I went and told him,
"Dog, I'm havin' problems
with this nigga down here."
He comin' with me, and
he gonna whoop some ass.
He don't pull no gun, no robbin'
nobody, he uses his hands.
And he was one of my
role-dogs, that I knew.
One time, he told me, say,
"SB, look, this nigga over
here, dog, he buyin' some Sherm.
"And the nigga had owed my girl some money
"and he didn't pay,"
and he's like,
"Man, that nigga hit that
Sherm, SB, get that nigga, dog."
So, when he, after he got
the water from 'im, I said,
"Dog." I said, "Homie, uh,
let me get a stick, dog."
He's like,
"Ah, man, I ain't gonna
give you none of this, man.
"This is my own shit.
I paid for this shit."
I said,
"Nigga, so you gonna be
like that, nigga? Huh?"
He's like,
"Man, go on with that shit."
I say, "All right, dog."
I look this way, and after I
turn my head back this way,
I fired on 'im.
I can tell you that I
knocked the nigga out,
and, as I'm friskin' 'im,
shakin' 'im down and shit,
I take the thing of his hip,
he had a chain to somethin',
and as I'm pullin' his,
it's like it's stuck,
so I yank it, right?
And when I'm gettin' ready to run,
the nigga tapped me in the street.
I don't even know that he,
I thought I'd finished 'im!
Some kinda way, he woke
back up, chased me,
tackled me in the street,
and outta nowhere.
I'm like,
"Man, get this nigga up off me, dog!"
Then, Big Will come up outta his house,
I mean, when he hit that dude,
Big Will got a name for Big
Will not for just his hands,
just, he was a big dude.
He was a big dude.
He hit that dude so tough,
man, to where it seemed like,
he hit 'im from here to
past that camera, man.
That's how hard he hit 'im.
I was like, I seen it
from my peripheral vision,
what, how you call that,
I forget the word right now,
and when he hit 'im, I looked, and like,
"Whoa! Nigga hit that nigga hard!"
So I'm runnin', I get
over there on Hunt left,
and he was like,
"Dog, SB, just keep all that
shit. I don't need nothin'.
"I just got the money for you, dog.
"Just keep that shit."
I was like,
"You lookin' out, dog. You
sure you don't want nothin'?
"A hundred or somethin'? Why
don't you take a hundred out?"
He was, like,
"Just give me $20, SB,
I'm straight with that.
"Just give me a dub."
Slammed him 20, right?
So this nigga come, pull up, he was like,
"Nigga, give me some, too!"
I was like,
"Nigga, you ain't in on this, nigga!
"Better back up, nigga, I
ain't givin' you shit, nigga!"
So when I roll up to the gym, he say,
"Man, this nigga SB, beat
me outta my money and shit."
I said,
"Nigga, how the fuck I beat
you outta some money, nigga?
"You didn't do the
motha-fuckin' lick, nigga.
"Fuck you talkin' about?"
"Nigga, we can get down,
nigga. I'll knock you out, SB!"
I said, "Well, nigga, whatchu wanna do?
"Nigga, you wanna get down, nigga?
"I'll get down!"
So we wind up squablin',
and some kinda way, he
tried to pull my sweater
over my head and I come
up outta the sweater.
I choke 'im out. When I
get 'im up in the loop,
I choke 'im out. I put 'im
to sleep. I let 'im go.
Once he went to sleep, I let 'im go.
Police pull up in front and say,
"Everything cool?"
I was like,
"Yeah, dog, he's just sleepin'
right now, he's all right."
You know, and they was like,
"As long as everything is cool."
They pulled out, they
back up and they left.
This nigga woke up. He's like,
"Nigga, we gotta finish!"
I was like,
"Dog, I already won!"
You don't count that as a win, though,
to these mothafuckas over here, dog.
These mothafuckas play some
kinda way where they play dirty.
They play dirty, dog.
So me and the nigga went
back at it, you know.
Everybody like,
"SB, knock that nigga out!"
I was like,
"Man, I'm tryin' to knock the nigga out,
"the nigga ain't goin' to sleep, though!
"I'm hittin' the nigga
with everything I got!"
And we keep goin'.
You know, every time we'd run in there,
I hit 'im with a couple hits,
and shit, I ain't penetratin'
the son-bitch, just, I-
Later, come to find out,
this nigga is on PCP.
That's why I can't knock
this mothafucka out.
But, he became my boy because
he never had got an ass-whoopin' like that
from nobody over here.
He says, "Big boy,"
He says, "Man, you really
put them hands on me!
"You see how my face look? I
was sayin' I was tellin' you
"to go on and kick back, dog,
you kept comin' at me, man!
"Nigga didn't wanna do that!"
And, I really was lookin' at wise boy.
Shit, I ain't right, I did that damn good!
I did good!
'Cause I put hickeys all up
across that nigga's face.
I didn't even know it,
because, once I said, I said,
"Man, I can't keep on
fightin', I'm tired, dog!
"You know, somebody get this nigga, man!"
I was tired! Can't keep goin'!
And, if I had to give
him the rounds, he won,
'cause I was too tired, dog.
I smoked cigarettes. I'm up
here fuckin' up, drinkin',
smokin' weed.
I mean, I think I'm King
Babalouie, or somebody, you know,
shit you not!
And all the homies, this
niggas givin' me recognition.
I'm fightin' niggas, like, left and right,
so, when it came down to
it, and a nigga needed me,
they knew I was there.
If you needed a gun, if I needed a gun,
all I had to do was just
go to a homie and say,
"Dog, I need a strap, man.
"You know,
"I got a little issue with
this nigga over here, man.
"And I'm gonna blast the
nigga on the strap, you know."
One time, I robbed a
dough-bow, my homie said,
"Look, man. You need the
AK, take the K around there,
and spray those niggas."
I didn't rob the spot to kill no niggas.
I just robbed the spot because
I had a little drug problem,
and I thought maybe I can
solve the police problem,
by just takin' these niggas' shit.
I didn't know it was goin'
turn into no gun-play, though.
But like I say, it is what it is, dog.
I mean, I'm a strong mofucka
man, by nature, not by choice.
You know, I walk by myself
because I been in prison,
to where I follow niggas,
and all I follow them for,
was for trouble.
Now, I can follow my own
footsteps, and find good in it.
And find somethin' that can
be servin' a better purpose
in my life.
I only have a little bit left.
I don't know when God make,
send the Angel of Death to come get me,
but I know, eventually it will end.
And before then,
I wanna have some righteousness
on my side before I go.
That's my life, man. And that's
just how I want it to be.
Good.
I wish I knew how to do good
when I first started my life.
Life hard,
but I wasn't given a lot of
good when I was growin' up.
Sorry to say that, but it is what it is,
and that's the way it is.